[Aplausos]
[Música]
creo que no cabe duda suiza es uno de
los países más especiales deslumbrantes
y asombrosos de todo el mundo a pesar de
estar enclavado entre montañas y de no
contar con ningún recurso natural
destacable se ha convertido en uno de
los estados más ricos de todo el planeta
y también en un país repleto de
curiosidades por ejemplo es el lugar
donde se inventó el chocolate con leche
para uno su manjar y para otros un
sacrilegio también es aquí donde se
fabrican los mejores relojes del mundo
con perdón del apple watch y por tener
tienen incluso cuatro idiomas oficiales
a pesar de ser menos de nueve millones
de habitantes y eso no es todo hablamos
de un país tan tan peculiar que ni
siquiera tiene capital y no si en este
preciso momento ya te estás tirando de
los pelos y gritando a la pantalla verán
a berna pira del freno porque lo cierto
es que esa ciudad no es más que la
designada como sede del consejo federal
esto es del gobierno suizo que si en la
práctica es como ser la capital pero sin
nada que la reconozca como tal ahora
bien un momento para que esta especie de
paraíso montañoso con un entorno natural
más que envidiable sea también uno de
los países más libres y democráticos
además de uno de los menos
todo el mundo tiene que haber algo más
en esa lista de curiosidades al fin y al
cabo el chocolate obra milagros pero no
tantos pues si lo cierto es que hay algo
más justo aquí es donde aparece su
particular sistema político
[Música]
el sistema político suizo ha sido
catalogado por muchos analistas de
política moderna como poco menos que una
utopía una cosa tan rara hoy en día que
bien se merece un vídeo completo de
visual polític para explicarlo y es que
veréis el sistema político de suiza se
basa en tres principios fundamentales la
descentralización el federalismo y la
democracia directa hablamos de un país
en el que la ciudadanía lleva más de un
siglo decidiendo directamente sobre los
asuntos más destacados de la política
estatal de hecho en suiza- podemos
encontrar incluso lo que se conoce como
comunas sus particulares municipios
donde los habitantes del pueblo se
reúnen periódicamente para decidir las
cosas y votar a mano alzada es lo que se
llama la unsj de mind
por supuesto conseguir que un modelo así
funcione también no ha sido cosas
precisamente de unos pocos años la suiza
tal y como la conocemos hoy se empezó a
gestar en 1848 cuando pasó de ser una
simple confederación de cantones
independientes a un estado moderno con
su gobierno central aunque eso sí con el
poder muy pero que muy descentralizado
podemos decidir amigos que los cantones
son algo así como los estados en eeuu
las comunidades autónomas en españa o
los landers en alemania pero con una
autonomía política financiera y de
gestión muchísimo más grande en total
hay 26 cantones y más de 2000 comunas el
equivalente a los municipios
[Música]
los cantones suizos son los encargados
de gestionar la educación secundaria la
salud la cultura las infraestructuras
cantonales y la seguridad a nivel
policial y si para ello pueden decidir
de forma independiente cuánto cobrar y
cómo recaudar y gestionar sus propios
impuestos luego por debajo están las
comunas que gestionan la educación
primaria y los servicios de mayor
proximidad como la limpieza de las
calles o la seguridad local
al final sobre el estado central recaen
solo las funciones que atañen al
conjunto del país como por ejemplo la
política exterior el ejército o las
infraestructuras de alta capacidad que
vertebran el territorio todo lo demás es
cosa de los organismos territoriales
cantones y comunas pero llegados a este
punto estoy seguro de que estáis
deseando saber más sobre este peculiar
sistema político queridos amigos queréis
saber más sobre un país en el que los
presidentes sólo están un año en el
poder y los ministros son de distintos
partidos políticos pues bien veámoslo y
qué mejor forma de empezar que echando
un vistazo a su famoso sistema de
democracia directa atentos
[Música]
y democracia directa
la utopía hecha realidad os lanzó una
pregunta si os pido que penséis en una
democracia perfecta en vuestro ideal de
democracia cuál sería cómo sería
seguramente para muchos de vosotros la
respuesta pasa por un modelo en el que
los ciudadanos no se limiten a votar tan
solo cada cuatro años y luego dejar que
sus representantes hagan y deshagan a su
completo antojo pues bien suiza va
exactamente en esa línea
a suiza se le suele conocer como el país
de la campaña electoral eterna es
bastante probable que si algún día
tenéis la oportunidad de viajar hasta
allí veáis carteles electorales pidiendo
un voto favorable o contrario sobre
alguna que otra cuestión y es que los
suizos votan entre 3 y 4 veces al año
para pronunciarse sobre temas
específicos de política nacional luego
además están las elecciones
parlamentarias cada cuatro años las
cantonales y las comunales que en
algunos sitios obtienen incluso más
participación que las de ámbito mayor lo
que supone toda una anomalía en la
escena internacional
[Música]
asimismo los suizos también pueden
lanzar iniciativas populares y
referéndums por ejemplo las iniciativas
populares son un instrumento por el que
un ciudadano puede proponer una
proposición de ley que deberá ser votada
en el parlamento si logra juntar más de
100.000 firmas de apoyo y aunque esta
figura existen muchas otras democracias
lo cierto es que en la mayoría de los
países la rigidez de los requisitos los
solapamientos con otras normas y la
falta de hábito y cultura política hacen
que rara vez lleguen a tramitarse luego
además están los referéndums cuya
proposición en suiza- a diferencia de
otros países no está sólo en manos del
gobierno sino que las propias ciudadanos
también pueden plantear los sí sí tal
cual como lo escucháis
los referéndums son votaciones que se
organizan con el objetivo de aprobar una
norma de considerable importancia social
o tumbar una ya aprobada por el
parlamento para sacarlos adelante se
necesitan 50.000 firmas la mitad que en
el caso de las iniciativas populares y
justo aquí es donde cobra importancia la
cultura política y la movilización de la
sociedad civil en suiza- existen grupos
de presión con diferentes propósitos que
pueden recabar este número de firmas en
un plazo relativamente corto algo que
evidentemente sería muy complicado para
un ciudadano a título individual además
la constitución no puede sufrir ningún
cambio sin que éste sea votado por los
propios ciudadanos cualquier
modificación sea de la parte que sea
debe ser refrendada en votación así como
también cualquier proposición de
aversión del país a determinados
acuerdos internacionales son los
llamados referente
y obligatorios
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
todo esto supone en un año corriente
como 2021 se celebran cuatro consultas
populares una del 7 de marzo otra el 13
de junio otra el 27 de septiembre y la
última el 28 de noviembre eso sí ojo hay
que tener en cuenta que para que se
apruebe o rechace una iniciativa popular
o un referéndum no solo hace falta que
los suizos voten a favor o en contra
también votan los cantones como si
fueran entes en sí mismo en una especie
de sobre elección vinculante y además
para enredarlo todavía más no todos los
26 cantones tienen el mismo peso a la
hora de votar fijaos
entre los 26 cantones hay 20 completos y
seis medios cantones en el caso de estos
últimos el voto vale la mitad esto
significa que en la práctica un
referéndum podría rechazar se con la
oposición de sólo 12 cantones y como los
votos cantonales no tienen en cuenta la
población podría darse el caso de que un
grupo de cantones poco poblados hecha
sea bajo una iniciativa aunque en ellos
resida una cantidad minoritaria de los
electores para determinar el voto de los
cantones se tiene en cuenta el resultado
a nivel cantonal de la consulta si la
mayoría de la ciudadanía de un cantón
vota a favor entonces el voto cantonal
será a favor son por así decirlo contra
pesos adicionales creados con la
intención de reforzar la estabilidad y
evitar que las grandes áreas de
población tengan todo el poder de
decisión no me digáis que no es un
sistema sorprendente y admirable pero ya
lo veis el modelo de democracia directa
es algo más complejo que llegar y votar
sobre una u otra iniciativa para sacar
estas votaciones adelante se necesitan
organismo
de la sociedad civil y también vencer
los contrapesos existentes pero hoy no
ver qué ocurre con los representantes
cómo se legisla en suiza cómo es su
poder legislativo cómo funciona
exactamente es tan peculiar como lo que
hemos visto hasta ahora pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
el poder legislativo más sorprendente lo
primero que tenemos que saber es que el
sistema legislativo suizo es bicameral
es decir existen dos cámaras de
representación a la hora de proponer y
aprobar las leyes en el caso suizo hay
una cámara que representa a todos los
ciudadanos
el consejo nacional esta es la cámara
baja y está compuesta por 200
representantes que se eligen mediante
circunscripciones cantonales de tal
forma que los cartones con mayor
población reparten más escaños y luego
hay una segunda cámara que es el consejo
de los estados que representan los
cantones y es el equivalente por así
decirlo senado
el consejo de los estados 46
representantes 2 por cada uno de los 20
cantones completos y 1 por cada uno de
los seis medios cantones es decir en
este caso la población de cada cantón es
irrelevante al repartir los asientos
esto se hace así para reforzar la
búsqueda de consensos amplios que
abarquen el mayor número de territorios
y evitar así que los cantones más
poblados determinen todas las decisiones
el caso es que entre las dos entre ambas
cámaras forman la llamada asamblea
federal y en ocasiones para cosas muy
concretas ambas cámaras se reúnen de
forma conjunta dando como resultado la
asamblea federal unida
pero un momento porque las curiosidades
no terminan aquí se da la situación de
que la suiza es una de las políticas más
fragmentadas de todo el mundo por
ejemplo echarle un vistazo a la
composición del consejo nacional porque
esta es de hecho una de las claves de
todo lo que os vamos a contar a
continuación como veis el parlamento
suizo se caracteriza por estar muy
fragmentado según como se mire por tener
mucha pluralidad política hay entre tres
y cuatro partidos hegemónicos con un
peso muy similar entre ellos y luego
otros siete con representación
parlamentaria a ojos de cualquiera de
nosotros este escenario político no sé
seguramente nos haría pensar en la
situación de ingobernabilidad poner de
acuerdo a tantos partidos distintos que
tormento verdad pues no en suiza- esto
no sucede
y la política sois amigos es la de los
consensos el multipartidismo y la
coparticipación de hecho para que os
hagáis una idea el presidente del
consejo nacional solo puede estar un año
ejerciendo esa función luego cada año
otra persona es elegida presidente del
parlamento y si suele ser de otro
partido diferente al del anterior
presidente digamos que en suiza- existe
la idea de que hay que evitar a toda
costa la concentración de poder en tan
solo unas pocas manos y una de las
fórmulas que encontraron fue la de la
limitación anual de mandatos y un
sistema que fuerza los acuerdos entre
los distintos partidos os parece curioso
pues ya veréis cuando os contemos cómo
funciona el gobierno federal aunque eso
sí antes de pasar a ese punto dejadme
que os contemos una última cosa sobre el
poder legislativo sus funciones
[Música]
en un país tan descentralizado como
suiza el parlamento nacional tiene
también unas funciones limitadas por
ejemplo solo dedicarse principalmente a
aprobar leyes y normas de carácter
estatal siempre que éstas no pisen las
numerosas competencias de los cantones
también se encarga de las modificaciones
de la constitución o de la aprobación de
tratados internacionales que luego tal y
como os hemos contado tienen que ser
sometidos a referéndums obligatorios
pero sin duda las dos funciones más
importantes que tienen son por un lado
el nombramiento de fiscal general que a
diferencia de la mayoría de países no es
nombrado por el gobierno sino votado por
todos los partidos en el parlamento y
luego la más importante de todas es la
elección del presidente del consejo
federal que es el nombre que en suiza
recibe el gobierno central porque si el
sistema suizo es también un sistema
parlamentario de tal forma que al
presidente del consejo federal no lo
elige directamente el pueblo sino los
representantes los diputados pero
extrajo el momento porque sobre el
consejo federal el gobierno suizo como
os digo hay muchas pero que mucha tela
que cortar es posible que estemos ante
el gobierno más extraño de todo el mundo
y a la vez uno de los que mejor
funcionan un sistema de gobierno que
seguramente fracasarían casi cualquier
otro país pero que sin embargo en suiza-
ha supuesto estabilidad unidad de la
diversidad cultural y si también
progreso riqueza y libertad os apetece
saber cómo es este extravagante sistema
de gobierno
[Música]
el gobierno más curioso del mundo
os voy a contar una cosa que puede que a
muchos os resulte de lo más extraño
durante el pasado año 2019 el presidente
de la confederación suiza fue este tipo
luego durante el 2020 fue esta persona y
a día de hoy en 2021 lo es este otro si
lo habéis escuchado bien y no no os
asustéis no estamos ante ninguna especie
de crisis política épica los presidentes
federales suizos sólo están un año en el
poder desde el 1 de enero hasta el 31 de
diciembre durante lo que se llama año
presidencial de esta forma a principios
del mes de diciembre cada año se reúne
la asamblea federal unida para elegir al
presidente del nuevo año presidencial
que con casi total seguridad será de un
partido distinto al del año anterior
además no se puede reelegir a la misma
persona para el año siguiente tiene que
elegirse a otra distinta pero eso sí la
persona escogida tiene que ser alguna de
los siete miembros del consejo federal
que eso sí pueden ser reelegidos cada
cuatro años sin problemas vale vale ya
os ha explotado la cabeza pues espera
porque aún hay más
el gobierno federal suizo se rige por el
llamado sistema directorial esto implica
que los siete miembros del gobierno
tienen exactamente la misma
consideración a efectos de poder de
decisión y de derechos dentro del
gobierno nadie es más que nadie si lo
habéis escuchado bien suiza es
actualmente el único país del mundo con
un gobierno que es básicamente un
organismo colegiado el presidente
simplemente preside las reuniones y
representa al gobierno en sus relaciones
exteriores pero ya está nada más
[Música]
además el gobierno está formado desde
hace muchísimos años por cuatro partidos
distintos y se suele seguir la fórmula
dos más dos más dos más uno para
repartir los puestos entre los cuatro
partidos más votados recordad es lo que
os comentábamos antes de la
fragmentación parlamentaria pues eso
[Música]
y además para volverlo todo todavía más
complicado a la hora de formar el
consejo federal esto es el gobierno no
sólo se tiene en cuenta los partidos
políticos sino también la diversidad
cultural precisamente por este motivo de
los siete miembros cuatro vienen de la
parte germano parlante dos de la
francoparlante y una última de la ítalo
parlante y sí así de esta forma se
produce una composición del gobierno
similar a la distribución de la
población suiza a nivel cultural para
que luego pues nadie se queje el caso es
que al final todo esto que os estamos
contando sobre gobierno federal tiene un
efecto práctico el consenso digamos que
no vas a ver a un miembro del gobierno
suizo echar pestes sobre una decisión
tomada por la mayoría del gobierno como
si pasa en muchos países sin ir más
lejos aquí en españa
digamos que allí se tiene la idea de que
los siete miembros tienen que defender
como propias todas las decisiones
incluso si a título individual pues
éstas no les gustan ya sabéis unas veces
pero yo otras veces te ves tú y así
funciona el gobierno suizo no os parece
como de otro planeta lo acierto amigos
es que el sistema político suizo es
quizás uno de los mejores por muchos
motivos combinan la democracia directa
con la descentralización que se
materializa con el federalismo y además
garantizan la cohesión en una sociedad
muy diversa culturalmente y todo ello
fomentando el multipartidismo y la
política de consensos casi nada sin
embargo un momento porque como todo en
esta vida hay algunos retos a los que
este sistema se va a tener que enfrentar
sobre todo en el futuro retos que muchos
de ellos son muy recientes y que por
supuesto no existían cuando este sistema
fue diseñado y puesto en marcha queréis
saber de qué estamos hablando
exactamente pues atentos
[Música]
nada es del todo perfecto
el sistema político suizo es muy antiguo
y todavía funciona muy bien pero cuando
se creó la sociedad no era exactamente
como lo es hoy en día uno de los
problemas por llamarlo de alguna forma
está en que en última instancia
suiza tiene especie de veto federalista
de facto por ejemplo una ley aprobada
por el consejo nacional puede ser
rechazada por el consejo de los estados
que representan los cantones sin tener
en cuenta la distribución demográfica y
esto esto también puede darse en las
votaciones populares como os
comentábamos antes una reforma de la
constitución por ejemplo puede ser voto
a favor por el voto ciudadano y echada
atrás por el voto cantonal y ojo no
penséis que el que esto ocurra es algo
demasiado complicado los 13 cantones más
pequeños que acudirán tan sólo al 11 por
ciento de los votantes tienen capacidad
de bloqueo así que incluso si el otro 89
por ciento los electores votarán un
momento a favor estos podrían tumbar esa
decisión y viceversa hablamos de un
desequilibrio que ha ido creciendo con
el paso del tiempo y que hoy no sé qué
os voy a decir parece exagerado pero
además del veto fe de la lista de facto
hay otro problema que también preocupa y
mucho
[Música]
durante los últimos 50 años suiza ha
sido un importante receptor de
inmigración hasta el punto que más del
20% de la población residente en suiza
es extranjera hay más de medio millón de
personas con lengua materna extranjera y
también hay unos 400.000 musulmanes
ahora bien por qué es esto importante
pues el reto o problema está en que
únicamente los ciudadanos suizos pueden
participar en la política federal suiza
y luego sólo una minoría de cantones y
comunas reconocen el voto a los
residentes extranjeros y por supuesto
conseguir la ciudadanía es muy
complicado así que digamos que cada vez
hay un mayor porcentaje de la población
que de facto está excluida de la vida
política al menos a la hora de
participar
en fin ya lo veis el sistema político
suizo es de todo menos común es un
amalgama de curiosidades peculiaridades
y contrapesos que lo convierten sin
lugar a dudas en un sistema único con
muchísimas ventajas y si también con
algún que otro inconveniente pero ahora
llegados a este punto la pregunta que os
lanzó es qué opináis vosotros del
sistema político suizo queréis que en
vuestro país en vuestra sociedad sería
posible que existiera un sistema así
como siempre dejamos nuestras respuestas
por aquí abajo en los comentarios y si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis dar al botón de like i
suscribiros a visar politics si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]